la parole est à Monsieur rené Beaumont
pour le groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire
chez le Président Mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
mes chers collègues
mon propos et ma question s'adresse bien
sûr comme vous le savez déjà à Monsieur
le Ministre du redressement productif
féministe je vais vous parler de culture
ce soir vous parlez d'une guerre des
anciens et des modernes qui a été
réinventé c'est vrai en l'occurrence et
ou en quelque sorte vous allez le voir
et vous le savez déjà ce mail le bien
bien sûr mais aussi le mal
Amazon
le distributeur américain au 50
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
annuel expression même de la modernité
numérique du commerce dématérialisé
arrive chez vous monsieur le ministre
chez nous devrais-je dire d'ailleurs
1,12 millions d'aide publique
1,12 millions d'aides publiques pour la
création de 250 emplois sur
un millier annoncé à terme on n'a pas
précisé le terme dans un nouvel entrepôt
en Saône-et-Loire à sevré
alors c'est vrai que dans le contexte
économique
ultra déprimé actuel
où les licenciements succèdent ou
licenciement
dans tous les secteurs et partout en
France quel que soit la taille des
entreprises le plus souvent d'ailleurs
celle-ci mettant la clé sous la porte
sans crier gare
une telle implantation peut apparaître
comme une bonne nouvelle
mais comme vous le savez aussi plus rien
n'est simple dans notre monde compliqué
la médaille a un revers et la mariée
n'est pas aussi belle
dans le même temps en effet
les 26 magasins de Virgin un grand de la
distribution de produits culturels dans
notre pays
ont été placés en redressement
judiciaire pour une période de 4 mois le
temps de trouver éventuellement une
solution pour le millier de salariés
encore en poste chez Virgin
prompte a réagir votre collègue ministre
de la Culture madame Aurélie Filippetti
a fait un parallèle entre cette solution
cette situation et la nouvelle
implantation du mastodonte américain
le rendant en partie responsable des
difficultés des Virgin stores
mais elle n'est pas la seule à souligner
que cette société était à l'origine de
la concurrence déloyale car elle n'est
pas soumise au même contraintes sociales
et surtout fiscale que les autres
un véritable front anti-amazon des
distributeurs se développent depuis la
Fnac aux anciennes aux enseignes aux
enseignes pardon de toute la grande
distribution qui dénonce que cette
société
paye peu ou pas du tout d'impôts en
France
acteur eux-mêmes du commerce
électronique
qui ne mérite pas ou peut ces recettes
alors Monsieur le Ministre Ken
incohérence gouvernementale que ce
gaspillage de plus d'un milliard de plus
d'un milliard envisagez-vous pour éviter
ces coûteuses bavures merci la parole
est à Monsieur Arnaud Montebourg
ministre du redressement productif
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur rené Beaumont il est vrai que
Amazon
montre et une façon éclatante les
contradictions de la société actuelle
c'est à la fois un changement sociétal
ou de plus en plus de nos concitoyens
font leur course à domicile sans se
déplacer et attendre un service très
rapide de livraison à domicile et il est
vrai que le commerce classique petit
moyen ou grand car on pensait que cela
ferait nuisance d'abord au petit
commerce de détails en vérité y compris
à la grande distribution de détails qui
celle-ci n'échappe pas à cette mutation
généralisée et mondiale
nous avons deux solutions la nier ou
l'accompagner nous avons fait le choix
de ne pas la nier et de l'accompagner
tout en contestant ces excès alors je
vais vous expliquer et je me fais le
porte-parole temporaire et amical
d'Aurélie Filippetti la ministre de la
Culture pour vous répondre fallait-il ne
pas accueillir sur les territoires ou le
demander Amazon il y en a trois en
France Montélimar ça rend
ça rend dans le Loiret Montélimar dans
la Drôme sevrait en Saône-et-Loire et
Amazon a fait connaître son désir de
s'implanter sur un quatrième site à
Douai dans le Nord nous parlons donc
d'un total de création d'emplois d'ici
2015 d'environ 2500 nous avons deux
solutions soit dire nous ne voulons pas
de vous quitter la France ce n'est pas
la stratégie que le ministère de
redressement productif a choisi puisque
c'est le ministère de l'hospitalité
économique industrielle est-ce que
des collectivités locales peuvent
résister à la tentation
justifier humaine et naturelle de dire
nous n'allons pas vous accueillir nous
allons vous rejeter la réponse est non
ce ne serait pas sérieux et vous seriez
vous ancien président d'un département
que je connais bien le premier à
attaquer un comportement de cette nature
donc nous avons appliqué partout nous
l'observons des règlements qui sont
applicables dans toutes les
collectivités locales pour la totalité
des emplois quels qu'ils soient et qui
viennent s'implanter sur les territoires
néanmoins monsieur le sénateur le
gouvernement a entrepris des mesures
visant à soumettre les géants de
l'internet à une fiscalité
concurrentielle en tout cas de même
niveau de même nature que les
concurrents c'est bien le minimum nous
ne souhaitons pas que l'Union européenne
se transforme en immense paradis fiscal
pour les géants de l'internet
et c'est la raison pour laquelle la
France a pris l'initiative dans une
négociation motrice monsieur le
Président de faire évoluer le taux
d'imposition en liaison avec les
partenaires européens cette négociation
nous l'espérons devrait aboutir dès 2015
ne pas rejeter ce qui est utile et
éliminer ce qui est mauvais je crois que
nous pourrons être tous d'accord